[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
Whata Prof good day Walter hi Martin yes
we are here again are you okay I'm okay
but it's we're going from bad to worse
here it seems that's how it is the Bible
says that will happen but at least there
is some hope yes so let's open with a
word of prayer and get on with it our
heavenly father thank you that we can be
here thank you for these wonderful
truths that you present to us in your
word help us to make sense of it and
help us to understand these things and
also to implement it in our lives and to
to reach the world with this message in
Jesus name amen
amen Martin we've now completed the
first the second and the third Angel's
message and they must do their work in
the world right
yeah and then comes this other Angel and
he repeats the message of the second
Angel but with some additional
pointers now the second Angel was an
announcement that Babylon had
fallen and it gives the reason why they
fell because they imbibed of the wine
of the first Beast the Babylonian
construct they embi that wine absorbed
had doctrines and moved away from the
Simplicity of God's word yeah the third
Angel invites them back into the path of
Salvation outlined in the Bible as
opposed to babylon's way yes and then
comes another Angel and it repeats
that second Angel's message and it's to
give power unto the third Angel's
message yes so let's have a look at it
Revelation 18 it's a it's a marvelous
chapter and after these things I saw
another Angel come down from heaven
having great power and the Earth was
lightened with his glory and he cried
mightily with a strong voice saying
Babylon the great is Fallen is Fallen
that's the same is the second Angel's
message yes but then it tells
us that they've become a habitation of
devils and a hold of every foul spirit
and a cage of every unclean and hateful
bird so Babylon is controlled by demons
yes and Babylon has a false holy spirit
it's a foul spirit and it's an unclean
bird because the holy spirit is likened
to a clean bird it descend descended
Upon Jesus like a dove which is a clean
bird but this is an unclean bird it's a
foul
spirit and why has this happened because
the Nations have drunk of the wine they
embi the wrong doctrines the wrong Plan
of
Salvation and Humanity gobbled it up
line and
sinker and that is why there's
wroth not because god is
vengeful but because they have separated
themselves from the source of life now
who are the ones that have em bibed the
kings of the Earth have committed
fornication with her so Martin we must
be careful of politics right that's it
stay out of it because they all sit
under same table and stay away from it
but we also get another bit of
information that the merchants of the
Earth are waxed Rich through the
abundance of her Delicacies M the the
merchants of the Earth are controlled by
Babylon yes that means who's
Merchants they are all the the financial
places
the shopping centers everything
everything that has to do with money who
controls the financial system Babylon
controls it that's what it says in the
Bible so she's become a house of demons
she has a false holy Spirit they have
false doctrines and the kings of the
Earth are in cohoots with her and
enforce her doctrines and her dictates
and the merchants of the world make sure
that she becomes rich and increased in
Goods all kinds of goods yeah and
humanity is
enslaved all right verse four says and I
heard another voice from Heaven saying
come out of my people this is a general
call to separate yourself from the
Babylonian system from this whole thing
and whose people God's people and you
are not to be a partaker of a sins sin
by definition is the transgression of
the law yeah they are against God's laws
separate yourselves from them or else
you're going to receive her
plagues it's a very very
potent message and you either adhere to
it or you forfeit eternal life why
because the time has come where her sins
have reached unto heaven and God has
remembered her
iniquities her iniquities throughout the
ages yes they're all recorded for in the
Lord's book for the whole period of
6,000 years that sin was permitted yes
and this Babylonian system first in its
pagan form then in its Christian form
then in its conglomerate religious form
having swept all the systems into its
midst has to be
exposed and she's going to be destroyed
yeah let's make sure sin is
transgression of God's law 1 John 3:4
whosoever committeth sin transgresses
also the law for sin is the
transgression of the law Babylon is a
law
breaker God's law is forsaken by them
we've dealt with it in great
detail James 2:9 says but if you have
respect to persons you commit sin in
other words if I listen to them then I'm
a partaker of their sin yeah if you
acknowledge or do whatever they ask you
to you fall into that trap because they
are breaking the law of God and they are
passing their one chalice to you and say
drink and come and sin with
us so if I listen to their reasoning
rather than to the
reasoning portrayed in this book I'm a
partaker of their sin and the thing is
most of the time that will be the
politically correct portion yes you will
be very politically correct if you break
God's law yeah and then you will be in
opposite to God yes because Satan in the
ult society says do what thou Wilt is
the whole of the law so we can be sure
that Babylon is a transgressor of God's
law by
definition and obviously there's a clash
of
WS why are we called Clash of Minds
Martin because there is two mindsets in
the world and they Clash they Clash yes
we have a Clash of Worlds Matthew 610
thy kingdom come thy will be done in
earth as it is in heaven Heaven is the
earth doing the will of God as it is in
heaven no
no Mark 3:35 for soever shall do the
will of God the same as my brother and
my sister and my mother so how do we
qualified to be counted as God's
children you have to do his will right
let's make sure Ephesians 6:6 not with
ey Service as men pleases but as the
Servants of Christ doing the will of God
from the heart so not what men want but
what God wants correct or Hebrews
10:36 for you have need of patience that
after you have done the will of God you
might be receive the promise m is it
conditional yes yes you don't receive
the promise unless you do the will of
God no and as we've mentioned before in
the previous episodes all the about um
if you
do there is a requirement
in any anybody has a requirement even
Babylon has a requirement yes but they
they ignore the requirements of God and
Implement their requirements that's it
so even if you want to be part of their
system you're going to have to adhere to
requirements yes or one Peter 2 verse1
15 for so it is the will of God that
with well doing you may put to silence
the ignorance of foolish men or verse 17
from chapter 3 for it is better if the
will of God be so that you suffer for
well doing than for
evildoing have people suffered
throughout the ages because of babyon we
can look at the world
today and it's a consequence of the
Babylonian Doctrine yes 1 John
2:17 and the world passes away in the
lust thereof but he that doeth the will
of God abideth forever M the Bible is so
clear it's a choice Romans 2:7 to them
who by patient continence in well doing
seek for Glory and Honor and immortality
eternal life it's it's a theme
throughout the
Bible James 2:8 if you fulfill the Royal
law That's the Law of Ten Commandments
according to the scripture Thou shalt
love thy neighbor as thyself ye do well
love thy neighbor as thyself is a short
summary of the second table of the
decalogue that's it
how do you react to your neighbor and
the first table is how do you react
towards God yeah all right so what is
the opposite of doing well 2 Kings verse
13 of chapter
17 yet the Lord testified against Israel
and against Judah by all the prophets
and by all the seers saying Turn ye from
your evil ways and keep my
Commandments and my statutes according
to all all the law which I commanded
your fathers and which I sent you by my
servants the prophets Martin can it be
clearer than that not at all well it can
a little bit shorter Jesus said if you
love me keep my Commandments yes and if
you don't do it and you say you don't
have to you're a liar right one John
Martin it's very clear it's it's a
battle between two
mindsets now let's continue with
Revelation chapter 18 because that angel
is not finished we're not going to go
through the entire chapter but we want
to get the gist of it reward her even as
she rewarded you and double unto her
double according to her works in the cup
which she has filled filled to her
double but there must be a reason why
God Is So harsh with Babylon right
mhm how much she has glorified herself
and live deliciously so much torment and
sorrow give her for she said says in her
heart I sit as Queen and and I am no
Widow and shall see no sorrow she's very
full of
herself she thinks she has everything
under
control and she's not a widow she has a
husband but unfortunately she has the
wrong husband the dragon is her husband
yeah it should have been Christ because
she presents herself as a Christian
organization that's it with all her
other Affiliates around her like her
children and then therefore shall her
plagues come in one day death and
mourning and famine and she shall be
utterly burnt with fire for strong is
the Lord God who judges her and what the
Bible calls her a prostitute mhm the
punishment for prostitution was stoning
yeah unless it was the daughter of a
priest then the punishment was burning
yeah samat she is a priest she's a
church mhm therefore her punishment is
burning and the kings of the earth who
have committed fornication and lived
deliciously with her shall bewail her
and lament for her when they shall see
the smoke of her burning she will be
exposed and this is only when the
plagues start falling right at the end
they will see her destruction and they
will
whail standing a far off for the fear of
a torment saying alas alas that great
City Babylon it's interesting that the
alas is also repeated exactly also
there's two of them Fallen Fallen alas
alas because it was church and state in
Union that's why the kings are wailing
because they know that they are also
lost the church and the state has fallen
with B that Mighty City for in one hour
is thy judgment come modern this system
is going to be be destroyed we need to
know why and that's why there's a call
to get out yes come out if we pick up
the story in Revelation 17: 6 and I saw
the woman which is this church drunken
with the blood of the sainton with the
blood of the martyrs of Jesus and when I
saw her I wondered with great
admiration Martin if anybody wants to
know just a tiny fraction of her evil
needs then read Fox's book of Martyrs
true I've tried a few times to finish
that book this book is amazing and you
know in the F early portion of
protestantism's
existence this book together with the
Bible stood side by side on the shelves
so that nobody would forget that this
woman this church Roman Catholicism was
Dr drunk with the blood of the Saints
and with the blood of the martyrs of
Jesus how they tortured millions of
people how the Inquisition ruthlessly
put them on the rack burnt them with
fire the most horrendous torches I mean
we've shown in other lectures the
horrible instruments that they used
Martin her cup is full how can she ever
ever make good what she has done
throughout the centuries so the
announcement of the fall of Babylon is
to be repeated by the angel of
Revelation 18 and after the message of
the third Angel has completed his work
the message will add power to the
message of the third Angel and will
constitute the loud cry before the great
and terrible day of the Lord it's the
last invitation to humanity separate
yourselves come out of her that's it and
this is already in its infant s yes who
do you separate yourself
to those who keep the Commandments and
have the faith of Jesus that's it that's
it Revelation 1812 and4 quoted this
scripture points forward to a time when
the announcement of the fall of Babylon
as made by the second angel of
Revelation 14 is to be repeated with the
additional mention of the Corruptions
which have been entering the various
organizations that constitute B babyon
since that message was first given in
the summer of
1844 these announcements uniting with
the third Angel's message constitute the
final warning to be given to the
inhabitants of the earth Mar this is it
this is the final message that's it it
is the loud cry you either listen to it
and adhere to it and act upon the
promptings of the Holy Spirit or you
will receive the doctrines of devils and
of false spirit and it will show it is
part of the message to show since
1844 how the organizations churches and
everybody has come back to this beast
power correct all right Revelation 1811
and the merchants of the Earth shall
weep and mourn over her for no man buth
their merchandise anymore so the economy
cannot be separated from Babylon either
no
M are you very happy with the way the
economy is being run in the world no
it's terrible is it very pleasant when
you go to the the gas filling station
and you have to fill up and you see that
everything has doubled and tripled in
the last few days and they're having fun
right correct everything
increases and that's uh because of all
sorts of factors that even don't make
sense that don't even exist yes but
you'll just just close off pipelines or
whatever you want to do but let's not go
into that but it just means it shows you
your hands are cut off you're totally
dependent upon the system now when
there's a marvelous typology in the
Bible where in the Old Testament there
were similar situations which point to a
greater reality at the end of time and
explain these things in some detail I
wish we had time to go through chapters
26 27 and 28 of the Book of Ezekiel but
there this typology is presented in so
much detail it's
amazing let's just look for at a few
slippers Ezekiel
26 these chapters deal with two entities
the prince of TI and the king of TI but
they of course are typological of
Greater realities yeah so thus says the
Lord God to Tyrus shall not the Isles
shake at the sound of thy fall when the
wounded cry when the slaughter is made
in the midst of the then all the princes
of the sea now the sea represents the
Nations yes in in biblical prophecy the
waters you saw are peoples and
multitudes and Nations and Kings
right so the princes of the sea so the
entire world all the nations shall come
down from their Thrones and lay away
their robes and put off their broidered
garments they shall clothe themselves
with trembling they shall sit upon the
ground and shall tremble at every moment
and be astonished at thee so the princes
of the world were in cohoots with Ty
which is a type of Babylon and Ty is
also just another name for Tyrus Tyrus
so that's the city that was destroyed
and there was a prophecy that it would
be thrown into the midst of the sea that
prophecy took more than three centuries
before it was fulfilled to the tea but
we're not going into those details
amazing prophecy this also sounds
similar to wondering after the Beast all
right so you had the kings of the world
committing fornication with her and the
princes of the sea
seafaring uh we under maritime law for
example today it is a Marines system but
that's a very long story now thou son of
man take up a lamentation for Tyrus and
say unto Tyrus oh thou that art situate
at the entry of the sea which art a
merchant of the people for many
Isles so here is this Merchant aspect
that we picked up in Revelation chapter
18 mhm thus says the Lord God OT Tyrus
thou has said I am of perfect Beauty th
borders are in the midst of the sea thy
Builders have perfected thy beauty isn't
this what Babylon boasted about yes but
all and if you just look at the glitter
yes and the ships of tarish did sing of
thee in thy market and thou was
replenished and made very glorious in
the midst of the sea so here is this
system that controlled the
economy all the inhabitants of the is
shall be astonished that the and their
kings shall be sore afraid they shall be
troubled in their countenance the
merchants among the people shall hiss at
thee Thou shalt be a terror and never
shalt thou be anymore this was the type
mhm and the antitype is what's happening
now in Babylon yes and then if you
continue in that chapter then you will
see all the nations being listed one
after the other and sadly Judah and the
people of God as well yeah
also being locked into the
system and then it comes to the prince
and this King Ezekiel 28 son of man say
unto the prince of Tyrus thus says the
Lord God because thine heart is lifted
up and thou said I am God I sit in the
seat of God in the midst of the Seas M
it's exactly what the prince of Babylon
is saying as well exactly he's saying I
said as Queen shall never be a widow or
suffer loss of children and he sits in
the seat of God saying that he is God
yes
Thessalonians yet thou art a man and not
God thou that set thine heart as the
heart of God behold Thou Art wiser than
Daniel that's a big statement this guy
is
informed and there is no secret that
they can hide from thee he is partaker
of all all the secrets and secret
societies and you can even say with
surveillance yes so who's this Prince of
Tyrus in modern terms well he is the
prince of the Babylonian system and
today that would be the Pope the pope
with thy wisdom and With Thine
understanding thou Hast gotten the
riches and has has gotten gold and
silver into thy Treasures the richest
system on
Earth is the Vatican the Vatican
definitely
by thy great wisdom and by thy
traffic hast thou increased thy riches
and thine heart is lifted up because of
thy riches therefore thus says the Lord
God because thou has set thine heart as
the heart of God is going to be
destroyed
right so does the papacy claim the
position of deity definitely right let's
look at this quote from Pope Leo he
claims Divinity besides the numerous
medieval papal claims to being God on
Earth modern popes have not distanced
themselves from such
claims Pope Leo said these things about
the role of the papacy and the Roman
Church our thoughts went out towards the
immense multitude of those who are
strangers to the gladness that filled
all Catholic Hearts some because they
lie in absolute ignorance of the Gospel
others because they descent from the
Catholic belief though they bear the
name of Christians this thought has been
and is a source of deep concern to us
what a
blasphemy with a capital u yes let us
make man in our image for it is
impossible to think of such a large
portun of mankind deviating as it were
from the right path and they move away
from us
capitalized and not experience a
sentiment of innermost grief but since
we hold upon on this Earth the place of
God
Almighty they reckon they have this
power this is such a Blasphemous
statement we can show others that are
much worse we hold upon this place what
other can you make of me but God I mean
they have so many statements we don't
have to read them all and just important
like you mentioned in the opening of
that um
paragraph they haven't distance
themselves of this yes so people say but
you know those are the Medieval popes
they infallible remember that's it ex
cadra so let's go to a more modern Pope
let's look at what John Paul II had to
say in other Catholic answer tracts we
have shown that the church fathers
recognized that Jesus made Peter The
Rock on which he would build his church
that this gave Peter a special Primacy
that P Peter went to Rome and that he
left successors there which is of course
a load of nonsense yeah because the Rock
is always Jesus Christ so Peter had to
finded that Jesus was the son of the
Living God he was the Messiah and Jesus
answered on this rock on this statement
the church is built yes so so so Jesus
actually said to Peter I am the rock yes
and on this church we will build you are
Peter the pebble the pebble so they
claimed this power to themselves and in
this track we show that they also
understood that Peter's successors
shared in his special Authority or
Primacy in a wide variety of ways the
fathers attest to the fact that the
Church of Rome was the Central and most
authoritive Church they note as Ignatius
of an Antioch does that Rome holds the
presidency amongst other churches and as
irus explains because of his Superior
origin all the church churches must
agree with
Rome this is modern history nobody can
say that the Church of Rome has changed
this is arrogance of the highest order
and all systems are part of this whole
correct that's why they have this
Babylonian ecumenical system and that's
why they can add this sentence they are
also clear on the fact that it is
communion with Rome and the bishop
Bishop of Rome that causes one to be in
communion with the Catholic Church M you
have to be
fratti which is of course we've dealt
with that you cannot do that you have to
that's if and everybody that's why this
message is come out of her my people and
you know even if Pope Francis himself
hasn't stood on the stage and said I am
God he certainly does it here he has the
arrogance to sit on a great white throne
with four living creatures around him
and two cherubs covering him that is the
depiction of God yeah sitting on his
great white Throne wasn't this is
arrogance this is blasphemy so Pope
Francis leads the celebration of The
Vespers of sality of the conversion of
St Paul in 2014 concluding the week of
prayer for Christian Unity while he sits
on the throne as God what a blasphemy
yeah would you want to be part of the
system so you see if you in unity with
this you acknowledge what he's doing
absolutely so let's go and look at the
king of TI so the prince is his
representative now who's the king of TI
son of man take up a lamentation upon
the king of Tyrus and say unto him thus
says the Lord God thou
sealeste thou Hast been in Eden the
Garden of God every precious stone was
thy covering than it mentions all the
stones and it says the workmanship of th
tabrets and of thy pipes was prepared in
thee in the day thou was created Thou
Art the announed Cherub that coverthe so
thou was upon the holy mountain of God
thou walk up and down in the midst of
the stones of fire this is Satan being
described here when he was still Lucifer
yeah he's the king of TI that's it now
who gives the Beast its power and great
Authority the dragon the dragon so you
had the two you had the prince and you
had the king you have the Beast which is
the prince and you have the King which
is the dragon or Satan same system thou
was perfect in thy ways from the day
that thou was created till iniquity was
found in thee by the multitude of thy
merchandise once again here's again a
dealer they filled the midst of thee
with violence thy sin therefore I will
cast thee as profane out of the Mountain
of God and I will destroy thee Oh
covering cherub from the midst of the
stones of fire can we see Martin that
Revelation
18 is the antitype of these chapters in
Ezekiel no definitely yeah right and the
the consequences will be the same the
same total Destruction it's it's almost
as if God wants to make get very clear
he gave you a type an antitype and then
he confirmed it in Revelation so we read
that Babylon deteriorates to the
point where they become a house of
demons now they've always been a house
of
demons but they added to their numbers
and the Protestants joined them and
sacrificed upon the altar of
iniquity the Beautiful doctrine of
justification by faith yeah you become
part of Babylon and the result is you
become a house of demons so mod in
today's
world if you want to do what the Bible
says you are branded a fundamentalist
right so the papacy if they have moved
away from God's word must condemn anyone
who adheres to the word of God as a
fundamentalist that's it so actually a
fundamentalist was a good word for a
Christian but it's become a swear word
now it's become a swear word because
it's totally negating what the papacy
wants you to do correct so I would like
to say to the papacy publicly I'm a
fundamentalist and very proud of it
because I believe every word that
proceeds out of the mouth of the Lord I
I conquer you conquer you're in big
trouble Martin let's have a look well
just for interest sake this a few of the
clips that we're going to show we has
been taken out of a documentary series
that was made by Chris Lang U mystified
it's a very good series and I'll put the
um link to it it's available to watch on
YouTube yes I think it's wonderful that
that link is there people can look at it
it's very well done Stephanie is a
fundamentalist a term originating in
early 20th century protestantism to
describe Christians who believe that the
Bible is the absolute truth of God for
mankind
Pope John Paul II tried to recast this
term as evil and in
1999 he urged an Interfaith Council of
200 religious leaders to condemn
Christian
fundamentalists the group agreed that
religious fundamentalists who refused to
go along with the global ecumenical
movement are to be
silenced the Jesuit Pope Francis who
says his spirituality comes directly
from Vatican 2 carries the same
message a fundamentalist group even if
it strikes no one is
violent we must be specially
attentive to every type of
fundamentalist with the state of the
world today we need a moral voice like
Pope uh Francis the focus on humanity is
is very critical right now because
there's so much polarization and
divisiveness and conflict in the
world in recent years Pope Francis
joined a coalition of leaders
representing some of the largest and
most powerful companies on Earth
according to the press release the
partnership puts the Coalition members
under the moral guidance of the
Pope Pope Francis presents what appears
to be a Kinder gentler
papacy after all he says his
spirituality comes directly from Vatican
2 has the papacy
changed
no the right to religious liberty is not
a supposed right to error and has due
limits which are inherent according to
the requirements of the common
good because all these stories you've
heard about Francis about picking his
friends up in his pop Mile and taking
them and all that going out to visit
people this he hasn't changed his spots
Martin a leopard cannot change its spots
right no she's still the same she hates
the Bible and the Bible believing
individuals so if we we can just make it
also very plain the they hate those that
keep the Commandments of God and have
the faith of Jesus yes and if somebody
disbelieves that they hate the Bible
they hate a specific one that's it they
hate the received text yes and they have
called the Bible the King James in
particular that poisonous
ASP and they they claimed that they want
to destroy it yeah so's become the
habitation of devils and the hold of
every foul spirit and a cage of every
unclean and hateful bird and we have to
look how this progressed yeah and M she
has
claimed that she will not suffer loss of
children and the
ratzinger pop
Benedict he's the one who
said she's the mother of all the
churches she's not the sister and the
the children must return to her so
protestantism must come back as well as
all the other churches that separated
from her must come back and she publicly
in Revelation claims that she will not
suffer loss of children yeah they will
come back so when you return to Babylon
you become part of Babylon so let's see
how the churches have submitted again to
the power of Babylon and interesting
this is since 1844 yes it's all the
corruption that has come in since 1844
remember the 1844 The ecumenical
movement started we had that quote in
the previous lecture and that's also
when the Three Angels messages had to be
proclaimed again correct because that's
when it started your Holiness may I
present rever Wesley Granberg Michaelson
The General Secretary of the Reformed
Church in America your Holiness may I
present Reverend Dr Clifton kirpatrick
the state Clerk of the general assembly
of the Presbyterian Church in the United
States your Holiness may I present
Reverend Dr William J Shaw president of
the National Baptist convention United
States your Holiness may I present
Bishop James Leed general superintendent
of the international Pentecost Holiness
Church your Holiness may I present Dr
LEF Anderson president of the National
Association of
evangelicals cence may I present Bishop
David H Beni president of the Atlantic
District of the Lutheran Church Missouri
Senate your Holiness may I present Elder
Bernice King Daughter of the civil
rights leaders Martin Luther King Jr and
Coretta Scott
King your Holiness may I present the
right Reverend Mark CIS Bishop of the
Episcopal dicese of New York have the
children returned to the mother the one
after the other so let's just just let's
just listen to what Tony Palmer said
he's now dead but he represented the
charismatic arm and then of the
Protestants and then of course the
unification again with Rome
yes it's the glory if you accept that
Christ is living in me and the presence
of God is in me and the presence of God
is in you that's all we need because God
will sort out all our doctrines when we
get
upstairs 1999
the Roman Catholic church and the
Protestant Lutheran Church signed an
agreement that brought an end to the
protest brothers and sisters Luther's
protest is
over is
yours
come on the man ask us to pray for
him oh
Father And since we know not how to pray
for him as we ought other than to agree
with him in his quest and and his his
his heart for the unity of the body of
Christ so father we just all of us now
according to scripture when we know know
not how to pray as we ought we pray for
him in the spirit we receive utterance
in the Holy Ghost we receive prayers of
faith we receive sir we receive words
that are not our
[Music]
own all of these
leaders
represent literally tens of thousands of
people that love you that believe God
with
you and in answer to your
request we have just prayed for you and
with you and we did so in the
spirit we thank God for
you and
so all of us declare
together be
bless I'm telling you right now Heaven
is thrilled over
this they have become a house of demons
a house of every unclean and detestable
bird Martin this is very very serious
and I cannot see Heaven being thrilled
over that heaven is a gust shivering and
and the message has to go out Babylon
has fallen has fallen she has become a
house of demon a house of every unclean
and detestable Bird come out of her my
people that you receive not of her
plagues for her sins have reached up to
heaven Martin how are they going to
achieve this well number one he was
speaking in
tongues an a language that neither
Heaven nor angels understand not even
himself
and Jesus has always appealed to the
mind as well as the
heart and music is going to play a very
important role because we read in Daniel
3:5 that at what time you hear the sound
of the Cornet the flute the harp the
sackbut the sultry the dlon and all
kinds of music You Fall Down and Worship
the golden image that Nebuchadnezzar the
King has set up they've set up an image
to the beast that's it they've become
part of Babylon and they're going to use
music to hypnotize Humanity into
believing that it is the holy spirit
when it is a foul Spirit yeah definitely
Elvis would sometimes read passages to
his audiences from blavatsky's book The
Voice of the silence it's a book that
promotes Eastern Hindu meditation as a
path to
self-realization while the Beatles
practiced and promoted maharishi's
Transcendental Meditation
while he was in India John lennin wrote
to a fan Transcendental Meditation is
not opposed to any religion it is based
on the basic truths of all religions the
common denominator actual experience of
God known as Vatican 2 launched in Rome
with more than 2,000 Catholic bishops
from around the
world Vatican 2 helped paid the way for
Interfaith ISM promoting Unity between
the world's religions by sharing the
Catholic Church's Mystic Treasures that
is its contemplative
Traditions the term contemplative life
was historically related to various
monastic orders of monks and nuns whose
lifestyles are oriented towards
aesthetic practices and contemplative
prayer a form of
mysticism we were asked by the Vatican
to to get involved in dialogue with
Eastern meditation and with Eastern
monasticism as the area in which
Christianity had the most common basis
according to Vatican 2 they would play
the main role in the evangelization of
the world and that's exactly what
happened we will now see how Interfaith
ISM promotes virtually the same world
view as witchcraft who are we and most
people don't know you came forth from
God your deepest DNA is divine what
you're doing in contemplation is moving
to a level beneath your thoughts at the
level of pure being the level of of
really what we call Pure Consciousness
the mystical contemplative non-dual mind
and I use those three words
interchangeably they have the same thing
it's not just two there's a communing a
fusing where you become aware of the
very presence of God in you and as you
so it's all a matter of Awakening it's
all a matter of awareness and if you're
accessing the now God being
Consciousness what is use whatever word
you're comfortable with it doesn't
really matter it doesn't really matter
it doesn't really matter Richard Roar is
consistent with the book The Common
heart a 20-year review of annual
Interfaith Summits with Buddhist Hindu
Sufi Muslim Jewish Christian and Native
American Shaman participants where they
agreed that God is too big to fit into
one religion Spiritual Authority is
based on inner experience and a person's
soul is
divine that Holy scriptures are only
respected if they lead to the greater
Authority self-knowledge
these Concepts about God and the nature
of man are identical to Witchcraft a
form of
shamanism but
are they listening to doctrines of
devils oh for sure and is it only
Catholicism or all the religions
including protestantism that's it all
religions including
protestantism or Christianity for that
matter and you know like you mentioned
it's so they use Music even Christian
music to implement these things now this
music plays such an important role
because it puts you into an altered
state of consciousness and whether you
do that in a church setting whether you
do that in a Gambling Hall where you
have this music that puts you in an
Altered States Of Consciousness or
whether you go into a shopping mall
where you have all kinds of music that
switches off your cognitive function so
that you become a a purchasing robot Y
and people get addicted to it you do
they become M
addicts and ignot spirituality is
brought into the churches M IGN naian
spirituality is Jesuit teaching
emanating from demonic visions that the
so-called St Ignatius Lola had so the
spiritual exercises this is a modern web
page describing this are a compilation
of meditations prayers and contemplative
practices developed by St gatus Lola to
help people deepen their relation ship
with God these are works you go through
phases you use all your senses you use
the sense of sight you use the sense of
smell you use the sense of taste and
touch and you place yourself into those
situations let's say a Biblical
scene and then you become a partaker of
the scene and you
communicate with the people around you
whether it be Mary or Joseph or Paul or
whoever ever it is and these people are
dead therefore you are communicating
with demons and receiving demon
instruction you see it's very scary
because it can like you just mention it
now somebody will say oh but that's not
what I'm doing that's exactly what
you're doing but the problem can be that
you don't have to do it in that state
you can just sit there and contemplating
the whole time of what would be the
message to you yes and then concoct up
something that's not even biblical and
one of the methods they use is
repetitiveness you have to repeat
phrases or words or even one name even
the name invoking the name of Jesus for
example you repeat it over and over and
over and the Bible says do not be like
the pagans that repeat over and over
because this puts you in an altered
state of consciousness it may even be
dangerous to read a a chapter or a
portion over and over and over and over
because that can also happen then well
that's what they call Divine reading
they don't read what the Bible says they
read it as a mantra repeating it over
it's called lecto deina reading Divine
reading it's
demonic the most common way of going
through the exercises now is a retreat
in daily life which involves a
month-long program of daily prayer and
meetings with a spiritual
director uh the Bible says that if you
listen to these people other than the
word of God it's
sin I need no spiritual director I have
a spiritual director it's called the
word of God Amen Rick Warren in The
Purpose Driven Church said that the
spiritual formation movement had a vital
message for the church and has given the
body of Christ a wakeup call The Settle
back Pastor Lon wit writes about the
contemplative prayer visualization in
his article titled enjoying God's
presence in solitude we are designed to
enjoy the presence of God but that's
easier said than done in this article
what uses Thomas meron as an example of
someone who knew about solitude but
Merton's Solitude was connected to his
Buddhist
sympathy and Merton likened
contemplative prayer to an ALICE
drip that's where you had the music of
The Beatles who by the way were Jesuit
controlled all of this come in they have
become a house of
demons and if you listen to this sweet
contemplative music Martin it's hypnotic
get out before you are hypnotized and
caught he finishes his article with the
goal of solitude is not so much to
unplug from my crazy world as it is to
change frequencies inducing Alpha
rhythms so I can hear the father you are
hearing demons Martin That's the problem
if like you mentioned in a previous talk
that we had if you want to hear God
speak read the Bible out loud yes
exactly so what does Rick Warren have to
say on some of these issues let's
listen I am nothing but
impressed by uh this new pope amazing
first place in my book the three most
important characteristics for leadership
are humility integrity and generosity
and in the
first months of his uh uh of his
leadership he has shown those
symbolically what he has done for a
lifetime okay uh his humility of showing
up of you know paying his own uh hotel
bill and checking out uh uh you know
stewing all of the all of the The Bling
and other things the accoutrements of
power things like that this is a man who
spent his life working with the poor
this is a man who I happen to admire
because of his work with people with HIV
AIDS and as you know sleach has been
involved in in that we just had World
AIDS day where we we've been really
involved in helping try to remove the
stigma and end getting to zero uh by the
end of uh this decade if we can on AIDS
and so his his Integrity uh I love the
fact that before he starts talking
about uh you know businessmen being
greedy he talks about Bishops Being
Greedy okay and and and before he starts
talking about the low morals in the
world he talks about the low morals in
the church okay uh let's do a little
house cleaning at home first and and I
love
that so is this so-called Protestant
preacher praising the pope yeah and they
show Martin the pope washing the feet of
the poor people right yeah now he's
taking the place of Jesus Christ
yes because because he's another Christ
on Earth after all he sat on a great
white Throne right and
Martin Jesus was the only one MH who
washed the feet of the disciples but his
feet weren't washed yes wasn't necessary
to wash his feet because he had no sin
in him that's it but the papacy does the
same thing mhm whereas the Bible says
that we ought to wash each other's feet
but he's above his feet being washed
because he's taking the place of Christ
he's the
Antichrist The Plea of the prophets
Isaiah
48:20 go ye forth of Babylon flee ye
from the calans with a voice of singing
declare ye tell this utter it even to
the end of the Earth say ye the Lord has
redeemed his servant Jacob what this is
Isaiah speaking this is before the
Babylonian
captivity and he's warning flee from
Babylon
Jeremiah
51:6 flee out of the midst of Babylon
God repeats the message this is in the
time when the Captivity actually
happened when Jerusalem fell and deliver
every man his soul be not cut off in her
iniquity for this is the time of the
Lord's Vengeance he will Render unto her
a
recompense that was the type we are
living in the
antitype so let's read these quotes from
the book prophets and Kings those whose
Spirit God had raised quoting Ezra
1:5 returned under the decree of Cyrus
but God ceased not to plead with those
who voluntarily remained in the land of
Exile and through manifold agencies he
made it possible for them also to return
however the larger number of those who
failed to respond to the decrees
remained unimpress and even when
Zachariah warned them to flee from
Babylon they did not heed the
invitation that is a scary type and I'm
afraid we're going to have a similar
outcome today and then came a death
decree meanwhile conditions in me Persia
were changing rapidly Darius Estes was
succeeded by xerus the great during his
Reign those who had failed to flee were
called on to face a terrible Cris deves
having refused the way of Escape God had
provided now they were brought face to
face with death because there was a
death decree is there going to be a
death decree again yes so if you don't
want to heed the call come out you're
going to be caught in the same problem
there's an article in the review in
Herald through the prophet Zachariah as
well as by the late experience in his
troublous times of Esther and mordai God
had plainly warned his people to flee
from Babylon the time had come when it
was perilous to dwell longer in the
midst of heeden influence in view of
these changed conditions the priests in
Babylon should have been quick to
discern in the call who is on the Lord's
Side a special call to them to return to
Jerusalem so we have a special call to
return to the ways of God to keep the
Commandments of God and hold to the
testimony of Jesus to keep the
Commandments of God to have the faith of
Jesus that's it Revelation 18:1 and the
merchants of the Earth shall weep and
mourn over her for no man buth their
merchandise anymore so in that video we
saw that the pope had an accord with all
the merchants of the earth and whose
morality must they follow his his yeah
verse 12 the merchandise of gold and
silver and precious stones and pearls
and fine linen and purple and silk and
Scarlet and and all thine wood and all
manner of vessels of Ivory and all
manner of vessels of most precious wood
and of brass and of iron and marble and
cinnamon and odors and ointments and
frankincense and wine and oil and fine
flavor and wheat and beasts and sheep
and horses and chariots and slaves and
The Souls of men that covers about
everything right that's it but that
greatest merchandise is The Souls of men
this is
terrible and they do it liter as well
with human trafficking trafficking we
got that word also in the previous slide
right so if we turn to Revelation 17 for
a little bit of help it says there and
there came one of the Seven Angels which
had the seven vials and talked with me
saying unto me come ether and I will
show unto thee the Judgment of the great
that sits upon many Waters so that
church that controls the
nations with whom the Kings of the Earth
have committed
fornication and the inhabitants of the
Earth have been made drunk with the wine
of a
fornication so he carried me away in the
spirit Into the Wilderness and I saw a
woman sit upon a Scarlet colored Beast
full of the names of blasphemy having
seven heads and 10 horns what a terrible
depiction and the woman was arrayed in
purple and Scarlet colors and decked
with gold and precious stones and Pearls
Mar does the papery have the satire by
now I think people can start realizing
for themselves Ezekiel all of and
Revelation every time you can see the
depiction now of what's describing this
Beast yes having a golden cup in a hand
full of Abominations and filthiness of a
fornication but they're so arrogant that
the Roman Church is the only one that
depicts herself as a woman carrying a
golden cup if you walk into the Vatican
and you turn right into the side chamber
there's a huge statue of the woman with
a golden cup in her hand there's also
the depiction of course of Martin Luther
and Calvin being yeah
obliterated and Upon A fared was a name
written mystery she's a secret
society she has an external and an
internal Doctrine exoteric and esoteric
correct Babylon the Great the mother of
harlots and an Abominations of the earth
she's the
mother and the others no matter what
they are no matter what you call the
religious systems no matter how many
millions of adherence they have they're
children of hers and I saw the woman
drunken with the blood of the Saints and
with the blood of the martyrs of Jesus
and when I saw her I wondered with great
admiration Martin I would also wonder at
the longsuffering of God that's true h
and the angel said unto me wherefore did
thou Marvel I will tell you the mystery
of the woman and the Beast that carries
her which has the seven heads and the
ten horns so this woman this church that
controls the beasts the political
systems of the world and the consciences
of men yeah she was identified very
clearly Martin Luther showed the woman
riding the beast and the kings of the
world bowing down to her and he made
very sure that he put the paple triple
Tara on the woman's head mhm was the
world warned yes have they forgotten
they have they've returned like we shown
since the messages bless the pope just
go on back Babylon she become a house of
demons and this depiction in Martin
Luther's Bible of the two witnesses the
old and the New Testament and their
adversary the dragon with a triple crown
on his
head and then they put pressure on him
and he had to remove it and they put a
kingly crown on there and Martin Luther
was very upset so he had it redrawn with
a massive triple triara on the dragon's
head that's the enemy the dragon and the
papacy those
two and Martin you can think all the
other religions are the enemies maybe
even terrorists and whatever and you can
give them whatever names you like
they're all part of the system of
Babylon and they're all part of those
Brethren the Fratelli toti yeah have
nothing to do with them come out of her
my people be not partaker of their sins
because they are the sworn enemies of
the two witnesses the Bible and the
Bible alone the old and the New
Testament the type and the
antitype so Martin can we say that they
are in Rebellion against the word of God
oh definitely 1 Samuel 15:23 for
Rebellion is as the sin of WI witcraft
and stubbornness is as iniquity and
idolatry because thou has rejected the
word of the Lord he has also rejected
thee from being
King is God rejecting another king here
yes even the king of
TI you know Martin God is so
faithful he wants everybody to
understand and there are messages that
are coming out in the world which should
horrify people and make them take a
second look but they
don't this is new information 28th
October
2023 the Spanish Church sexual abuse
affected 200,000 children commission
fines more than 200,000 children are
estimated to have suffered sexual abuse
from Spain's Catholic clergy and
independent commission has found now
Martin this can happen in any Church mhm
but at this level I don't know 200,000
children abused in Spain and this
consistency yes there's another article
also new over 4,000 children abused by
Portugal's Catholic Church a commission
investigating the issue said 77% of
perpetrators were priests and most of
the victims were men Martin this is
terrible because the Bible actually
describes that people are being
victimized The Souls of men and human
trafficking takes place in these
organizations and it's glossed over with
a apology what about Canada's
residential
schools they were a place of
horror founded to carry out the genocide
of indigenous people that created
conditions that killed thousands of
children editors note this story is
being republished in the light of Pope
Francis visit to Canada to apologize to
the indigenous Community for more than a
century of abuses by missionaries or
residential schools across the country
it is replete in history if you go to
the Middle Ages what happened in those
monastic systems what happened in the
dungeons of those places where they had
the the little children that were being
sacrificed there it is a horrendous
system that's why monastic systems were
abolished in England for a time and the
horrendous things that went on over
there was just beyond compilation and
the mysticism that was involved and it
and it is a form of sex worship this
Pagan worship we saw that also in the
previous episode that's part of the old
Babylonian worship and sacrificing of
children was part of it now I don't we
don't want to go into all of those
details
but this system has become a house of
demons she's a house of every unclean
and detestable bird and anybody who is
assciates with her willingly Praises her
bows down to her is an enemy of
God here's an article what does a plary
indulgence
mean liability insurance for our sins
Martin this is in our time this is
2022 yeah all believers who attend Pope
the Pope's ceremony on world day of
grandparents and the elderly on July 24
2022 or in one of the events taking
place around the world can purchase a
plenary
Indulgence how would you describe that
you pay and have your sins
forgiven there's a connection between
indulgences and forgiveness of sins but
if I am granted an Indulgence then my
sins are not forgiven but rather it is
the remission of temporal punishments
for sins that is there's a difference
between forgiveness and making amends
for harm now these indulgences are
taking place under the direction of Pope
Francis yes so it's not something of the
Middle Ages no and now why they doing
this so publicly they are rubbing it
into the face of the Protestants saying
we don't care that you exposed us you
are back with us and we will show you
that we have not changed you know how
ridiculous this becomes yeah then I have
a system Martin that on a Friday the
church bells will ring yeah to
commemorate so they say the death of
Jesus on the cross and if during that
period when the Bells Are Ringing you
say five our
fathers then you receive an
Indulgence a complete complete remission
of the punishment of sin this is such a
blasphemy this is such a stupidity that
Protestants should go along with this is
just astounding to me and still continue
with the ecumenical movement no and
unfortunately like we've shown in the
previous one that has to do with the
Mark if you want to for take their
excuses for keeping the mark that Sunday
worship then on unfortunately you are
adhering to the system you are
worshiping the Beast before he was
expelled from Heaven Satan had an
acquaintance with God he knew his
character but ever since then his effort
has been to misrepresent that character
it is at his suggestion that religion
has been made a series of penances and
mortifications or of a splendid sights
and pageant trees there are many forms
of religion instituted by the enemy of
God that are as christless as was the
offering of Cain all of these
activities to receive remission are as
christless as was the offering of Cain
and can you imagine a Protestant
Minister partaking in an ecumenical
process bowing down to images can you
imagine that happening in the world
today that is a blasphemy against God I
am
horrified so when we talk about
Revelation chapter 18 the whole chapter
shows that Babylon that has fallen is
the churches who will not receive the
message of warning the Lord has given in
the first second and third Angel's
messages when the bell rings say five
our fathers is to take the place of the
righteousness of Christ how low can you
fall
they refused the truth and accepted a
lie they refused the message of Truth
see Thessalonians 2 where the Antichrist
is clearly defined he sits in the temple
of God in the Church of God pretending
that he is God the message in the 18th
chapter of Revelation is plain and
clearly defined for all nations have
drunk of the wine of the Roth of a
fornication and the kings of the Earth
have committed fornication with with her
and the merchants of the Earth are waxed
Rich through the abundance of her
delicacy Anyone who reads this chapter
need not be
deceived the wine of Babylon is the
exalting of the false and spous Sabbath
above the Sabbath which the Lord Jehovah
has blessed and Sanctified for the use
of man also the immortality of the Soul
now we spoke about that when we spoke
about the mark of the beast these
Kindred heresies and the rejection of
truth convert the church into Babylon
Kings Merchants rulers and religious
teachers are all in corrupt Harmony
we've seen them yeah and what will be
the result Martin Revelation
16:12 and the sixth Angel poured out his
vial upon the great river
Euphrates and the water there of was
dried up that the way of the kings of
the East may be prepared the great river
Euphrates they're all excited now
because it is literally drying up
because they built a dam yeah that's not
what's meant here that's not what's
meant here literal Babylon is gone the
waters you saw are the multitudes that
fed her yeah so the waters represent
peoples and Nations and multitudes and
Kings but those Waters will dry up and
this is at the end when the plagues Fall
Mountain they will see that God was not
in that movement and the kings of the
East and I saw the glory of the god of
Israel come from the way of the East
this is so important because these
carismatic churches that want to say
that the kings of the East are China and
Russia nothing to do with them and then
I saw the unclean furets like frogs come
out of the mouth of the Dragon that's
all the spiritualistic religions the
contemplative prayer and all that
nonsense that we just saw and out of the
mouth of the Beast that tells you that
you can get get remission from the
punishment of your sins by just visiting
an elderly person what a load of
nonsense I'm not saying don't visit an
elderly person by the way no and out of
the mouth of the false prophet we saw
the Kenneth Copeland and the Rick Warren
and the way that they speak and are
telling you that this is the way the
truth and the life no Jesus is the way
the truth and the life for they are the
spirits of devils working Miracles which
go forth unto the kings of the earth and
of the whole world to gather them to the
Battle of that great day of God almighty
this is The Clash of Minds that's it
this is the battle of Armageddon this is
where you have to make your decision you
either stay with the system or you come
out Jeremiah 51:9 says we would have
healed Babylon but she's not healed what
she cannot be healed there's no peace to
be made between Christ and S Satan no
get behind one of them you have to yield
to one of them that's why you have to
forsake her and let us go everyone unto
his own country for her judgment reach
unto heaven and is lifted up even to the
skies Revelation 19:20 and the Beast was
taken and with him the false prophet
that wrought Miracles before him with
which he deceived them that had received
the mark of the beast and then that
worshiped His Image these both were cast
alive into the Lake of Fire burning with
Brimstone Martin the religious systems
are going to be destroyed yes it's
interesting the dragon is not there no
because he's still going to survive for
a millennium for a thousand years but
there will be no one to deceive because
they'll all be dead true there will be
no thousand years of Peace down here
that's a false jesuitical Doctrine
that's also been swallowed by
protestantism it's part of the wine of
Babylon so I'm want to sum it up
this other Angel says Babylon has
fallen and he gives a view of all the
Corruptions that have come into the
churches since the first announcement of
Babylon yeah now God has been so good he
has repeated this message over and over
that people should get it the Protestant
Reformation defined it very clearly yeah
Protestants forgot in 1844 the message
was repeated mhm they refused to go
along with it they went into the
ecumenical movement yes and now this is
the final call this is the final this is
the final call this is the loud cry
either we accept this message and
separate ourselves from Babylon and join
up with those who keep the Commandments
and have the faith of Jesus or we
receive the plagues may God give us
wisdom to make the right choice shall we
pray
please Heavenly Father what
a powerful
warning and warning a warning that comes
from a heart of love because it has been
repeated over and over and over
again not only has it been repeated it
has been defined over and over
again and nobody wants to do it please
Lord send your spirit that people may
make the right choices my prayer in
Jesus name amen
[Music]
amen